[Musique]
lorsque mon fils martin est né il n'y a
pas eu une naissance mais c' est la
sienne bien entendu les nôtres en tant
que parents et puis ces quatre
naissances que je n'ai jamais vu venir
les quatre naissances de ses grands
parents alors quand un premier enfant
arrive dans une famille c'est comme un
étage de fusée qui se rajoutent les
enfants deviennent parents les parents
deviennent grands parents et les grands
parents deviennent arrière grands
parents et sans qu'on s'en rende compte
c'est la place de chacun qui est
questionnée
alors je ne sais pas à quel niveau de la
fusée vous êtes si vous avez déjà vécu
cette révolution mais pour moi elle fut
pas forcément évidente car qui dit
quatre grands-parents 10 4 réactions
complètement différentes le premier
ultra émotif mais complètement désemparé
le deuxième qui ne savait absolument pas
pourquoi il était là le troisième
beaucoup trop informés et le quatrième
qui était peut-être comme je l'attendais
alors suivre la naissance et l'évolution
de ses grands parents autant vous dire
que ça m'a passionné
ça m'a passionné par ce qu'avance ce
moment je m'étais jamais posé la
question de savoir si mes parents
étaient prêts à devenir les grands
parents que j'imaginais il avait été par
an avant
mais pour eux ça n'a pas été aussi
simple car devenir grands parents ça
vous tombe dessus sans vous n'ayez rien
demandé à personne
et autant vous dire que 35 ans après
nous avoir eu ma soeur et moi non
seulement la société avait pas mal
évolué mais en plus ils ne se
reconnaissaient mais absolument pas dans
les grands parents qu'ils avaient connue
alan mes parents ces nouveaux grands
parents ce sont les baby boomers 10
millions de français entre 50 et 70 ans
une génération qui a connu et qui a été
actrice de mutation sociale culturelle
technologique complètement inédite
est ce que vous vous rendez compte qu'à
14 ans ma mère a vu les femmes de la
famille avoir le droit de travailler
d'ouvrir un compte bancaire sans
demander l'avis de leur pari leurs maris
qu'à 25 ans elle a vu la légalisation de
l'avortement est ensuite mes parents
qu'est ce qu'ils ont vu ils ont vu la
parité ils ont vu le mariage pour tous
et après avoir vécu tous ces
bouleversements
après avoir évolué avec leur temps
aujourd'hui ils ont à nouveau rôle mais
ce nouveau rôle ils doivent le concilier
avec le reste ils doivent le concilier
avec leur vie professionnelle
ils doivent le concilier avec leurs
parents qui ont de plus en plus besoin
d'eux peut-être au fur et à mesure que
le temps passe et puis ils doivent le
concilier aussi avec les petits derniers
qui sont encore à la maison et qui
terminent leurs études et est ce que
vous savez pendant combien de temps
mes parents ou grands-parents 25 ans
quand ils sont rentrés dans cette
maternité mes parents ont entamé ce
quart de siècle de vie où tout est à
inventer leur rôle en tant que grands
parents les relations qu'ils vont tisser
avec les petits enfants
et puis la place qu'ils vont donner à
tout ça dans leur vie
mais ce qu'il ya derrière tout ça
finalement ce sont les années qui
passent c'est le fait de vieillir c'est
ce fameux coup de bambou qu'ils ont eue
et qui leur a fait dire par de minces
ça y est je crois bien que c'est mon
tour et ça ça m'interroge voir mes
parents vieillir ça m'interroge
dans quelle société est ce que j'ai
envie de les voir vieillir et j'irai
même plus loin dans quelle société est
ce que moi j'ai envie de vieillir
alors quand on imagine cette société
cette société où on se sentira bien
quelle que soit notre âge je pense qu'on
pense à notre environnement
on pense à ce qui nous entoure on pense
à l'escalier de métro on a peut-être
descendu pour venir ici
on pense à cette baignoire qu'il faudra
peut être penser à remplacer on pense à
ce petit trou là qui nous embête
quand on va à la boulangerie mais on
pense un petit peu moins souvent à notre
vie professionnelle
pourtant le monde du travail est un
miroir de notre société
c'est un véritable incubateur et je suis
persuadé que si notre regard sur l'âge
change en entreprise les lignes bougent
rond ailleurs tenez un exemple je suis
sûr vous avez des collègues autour de
vous des collègues qui partent à la
retraite de plus en plus tard des
collègues qui sont grands parents sauf
que l'entreprise ait de grands parents
on ne le dit pas j'avais même un
collègue qui n'osaient pas la dire
pourtant il en était fier ses petits
enfants mais grand père grand père en
entreprise mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire vieux ça veut dire
dépassé ça veut dire accepter à vous
mêmes avoir franchi cet étage de fusée
et ça ça il n'était pas prêt n'était pas
prêt à l'avouer il n'était peut-être pas
prêt à voir ce qui allait avoir dans
notre regard
il avait peut-être peur peur d'être jugé
peur d'être discriminés et ça ça non
et ça s'appelle l'âgisme d'un autre côté
qu'est ce que ça aurait changé s'il en
avait parlé parce que les grands parents
en entreprise ça n'existe pas on se
rapproche des fêtes de noël il ya les
arbres de noël
est ce que les grands parents sont
invités aux arbres de noël
il serait peut-être fier d'y emmener
leurs petits enfants de leur montrer là
où ils travaillent de leur présenter
leurs collègues mais s'est réservée aux
parents et moi je trouve ça triste pour
tout vous dire je trouve ça dommage
et si tout simplement on changer les
choses
pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça
aujourd'hui j'aurais très bien pu vous
parler des seniors mais je vous parle
des grands parents parce que faire ce
pas de côté
ça change beaucoup de choses il ya de
plus en plus de grands parents dans
notre société
pour tout vous dire il ya même plus de
grands parents que de petits enfants
tout simplement parce qu'être grands
parents c'est pas qu'une question de
sens c'est une question de coeur vous en
avez tous autour de vous des
grands-parents de coeur ses grands
parents qui s'investissent auprès de
d'enfants qui pourraient être leurs
petits enfants et qu'ils aiment tout
autant et puis parce qu'elle grands
parents c'est une position c'est être
une charnière une charnière entre les
générations celles qui nous précèdent
celles qui nous succèdent
et puis ce sont des valeurs celles de la
transmission celle de l'entr'aide
alors je vous propose d'ouvrir les yeux
oui le temps passe et nous avons tous
envie d'avoir la chance de visiter
l'ensemble des étage de cette fusée
mais avant de continuer ce voyage
j'aimerais vous poser une question
quelle pierre allez vous apporter à
cette société pour que l'on soit fier et
heureux d'y grandir en âge merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à